you just talked to us at Tiff and you
told us that you and your pitch perfect
family are just closer than ever it's so
exciting they're doing Bumper in Berlin
I'm curious have you been approached to
make a cameo I don't know if any of the
girls have been approached about that I
mean obviously we just adore Adam to
find we love his character bumper so um
we couldn't be happier for him would you
oh well I think we all would yeah you
know I was thinking about how Elizabeth
Banks directed your second film now that
you're director Anna Kendrick I mean is
the possibility open for Pitch Perfect 4
would you want to step into those shoes
um I really enjoy the friendships that I
have with the girls and I think that
trying to be in charge of them is not
something that would benefit any of us
interesting so maybe not directed
growling cats is what I would uh refer
to it I mean socially it's wonderful but
um you don't want to tell Rebel Wilson
to hit or Mark exactly no thank you
she'll do what she wants and I love that
about her okay so maybe not directed but
are you interested do you feel like
Becca has more story to tell would you
do a forth
um you know I think we love each other
so much and you know I think we would
probably make 16. but
um yeah of course that's not our
decision
history talks what an exciting event
today why was it important that you be
here in DC
um well my dad is a history teacher um
so anything with the name history in it
is sort of a mandatory
um obviously the opportunity to speak
with Malala is just an honor um I'm I'm
I feel like I'm probably the most
nervous I've been for anything I just
met her and she's she's so sweet and
it's fine but um yeah I'm just honored
to be here on the topic of History
you've done a lot in your short amount
of years on this planet when you think
about Anna Kendrick's history what part
do you hope people remember most oh my
gosh
um that feels like an especially
difficult question to answer given the
context of you know interviewing Malala
and obviously her place in history but
um yeah I think um it's interesting to
be at a point in my life and my career
where I'm starting to realize like
sometimes I'm in rooms where I have the
most experience out of anyone and I
think that as a as you get older for
everyone but especially for women that's
a that's an odd transition and it's um
it's something that feels a little bit
scary because it forces you to kind of
come into your power
um but that's uh I'm sort of in a really
exciting time in my life so yes you are
director Anna Kendrick congratulations
you know this is your directorial debut
what was it about this project that you
were like this is what I want to use for
my Milestone achievement yeah um I've
loved the script for a long time and so
when the opportunity to direct it came
up I I sort of pushed myself off a cliff
and pitched myself and um the the story
is uh you know it's a true story it's a
really shocking and Powerful story and I
sort of want to use that framework to
talk about
um intimacy and gender issues and um
shame and you know just sort of try to
like dive into the the water a little
bit
um but it's also just a beautifully
written script and I'm I can't wait to
get started I mean how do you feel this
is exciting it actually I I thought I
would be I mean I'm you know I'm excited
I'm terrified of all the things but I'm
actually less terrified than I thought I
would be
um so again it's that
um it's that thing of sort of stepping
into your experience and your power and
like trusting yourself so I'm hoping
that I'm gonna be able to do all of that
you will you've got this and I think
it's interesting you're up in the air
co-star George Clooney is here at
history talks he's a pretty successful
director are you gonna be you know
poking him today asking for any advice I
know well this is um such a prestigious
event so happy to be here um that like
everything is so top secret that I'm
like oh like can somebody tell me when
George gets here and it's like the
itinerary itself is a secret we cannot
reveal so um obviously um if our paths
cross I'm gonna ask him if he has any
tips but uh I'm not sure because you
know I'm not I'm not trying to press the
Secret Service on giving me that info
[Music]